go watch the full interview I just did
with these guys but right now we got
blue bucks clan in the [ __ ]
building Clan way three coming out yes
sir if you're watching this it's out
right now go run that [ __ ] up
and let's just let's just get to it man
we're gonna have y'all do what y'all do
reaching out the [ __ ] they know where
my [ __ ] holds you to say they lost my
number didn't store my [ __ ] when I start
rapping they ain't even support my [ __ ]
couldn't find the engineer to record my
[ __ ] now these [ __ ] want versus can't
afford this [ __ ] now we selling out
shows fans know my [ __ ] [ __ ] can't
believe how this [ __ ] happened it's a
couple lines there in this big snap
Times Square pulled down we in the Big
Apple this didn't work I'll be probably
scamming big hacking she won the Benz
now I can make that [ __ ] happen through
her in that big truck like a kidnapping
this [ __ ] ain't as easy as we made it
look hoping [ __ ] had cables when I
needed jumps at my granny house roof
leaking every other month
she made me a man getting on that bus
huh look how I panned out remember
sleeping in the car I'm the man now in
the hood for holidays I'm giving hands
out same [ __ ] left me starving I think
hands out had a 9-5 but I got fired on
my day off I was finna quit the rapping
and it paid off
remember I was forced to walk the worst
streets [ __ ] told me seven thousand
just for one beat now I'll leave the
house and everybody on me now we selling
out these shows and [ __ ] know me
remember said he had a verse for me
never sent it remember when we dropped
on Soundcloud let him listen homies
hitting me from jail I couldn't send it
landlord banging on my door I know you
in there this [ __ ] ain't happening
overnight but now we've been here I
ain't got a couch no more I really live
here
oh
yeah
I can't wait three out now man wait
three out right now you already know man
blue box Clan let's go how this [ __ ] out
hey you just watched a crazy freestyle
and we drop one every week sometimes
more than once a week uh and they're
always presented by our family at LRG
now I love LRG I'm wearing look I'm
gonna just show you the new shorts I got
from them check out them shorts my boy
you know what I'm saying and got the
plain black tea the plain black LR GT
you know what I mean listen lrg's back
they just dropped the crazy Jason hoodie
with Jadakiss that's from like 2008 for
Halloween [ __ ] Flames go to the
website
l-r-g.com and this is crazy because
they're giving you 30 off when you use
the promo code bootleg 30 percent off
that's a significant amount of money
you're going to be saving when you go to
lrg's website Christmas is coming save
30 off just by going to the website and
using the promo code bootleg L Dash R
g.com we'll see you next week with a
crazy freestyle